All right, let's go back to the phones at
six one seven, eight three zero 47 50.
Going to our caller from the three three one,
one area code color from three, three one.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Her name's Curtis calling from Aurora.
Hey Curtis, what's up?
And I'm much first a happy new year to you
and the guys over there doing good stuff,
man.
Patriot mail.
Thanks a lot baby.
Appreciate that.
Um, my specific question was, so I'm in light
of the, uh, psychiatric nurse, left the voicemail
for ya.
And then some of the other great guests that
you've had on in regards to Trump, the narcissism
neurologically possible psychological issues.
My question is, um, you had a, you had a tweet
that asked a, if I'm not mistaken, what his
worst moment was and, um, 2019, uh, I thought
dangle the single comments were the lowest
and most deplorable comments ever.
I was wondering what you thought his worst
was.
I couldn't tell.
I mean, there's just, there's so many.
It's w I'm actually the wrong person even
to say what Donald Trump's worst moment was
in 2019 because I, I've become so desensitized
to the fact that we have this outrageous person
in the oval office.
So I, I actually am not well positioned to
tell you what the worst moment was.
All right, understood.
Understood.
Yeah, it's, well, I think he's had a lot,
I think he'll continue to have more just based
on the, uh, individuals he has, but, um, those
specific people who speak to that, uh, that
she had won, they always make for a great
and very enlightening shows.
So that's a good thing.
So I appreciate that.
Yeah.
Listen, I mean, I, every time we talk about
the Trump cognitive decline or mental health
stuff, there's always a portion of the audience
that says, you know, it's irresponsible to
be talking about a person who you've not personally
met or who hasn't been examined.
It's like, this is the problem that we can't
actually figure out what's going on because
he won't be examined and the behavior is so
erratic and examination would be appropriate.
Uh, so what else can we do?
We're left in a very tough position.
Very true.
Well, I hope we have a good rest of this year,
sir, and thanks for everything you're doing.
All right, my friend.
Thank you very much.
Great to hear from you.